beginning shortly after my PhD began to
work on a variety of issues related to
energy systems and particularly some of
the environmental consequences of energy
systems
I run a department at Carnegie Mellon
called the department of engineering and
public policy which in addition to
educating undergraduates also has over a
hundred PhD students all with technical
backgrounds who work on policy problems
where the technical details matter and
perhaps twenty to thirty percent of them
are working on energy related issues so
the Scott Institute at Carnegie Mellon
University first it's going to work on
trying to figure out how to use the
energy we already have far more
efficiently and that will require
technology but it also require changes
in social behavior and in regulation
second we need to worry about how we
find significantly additional sources of
energy and those sources need to be
clean reliable affordable and
sustainable it's going to require
substantial innovation both innovation
on technology but also innovation in
regulation and in social behavioral
areas the Scott Institute will do a
variety of things first and foremost of
course we will do research and we'll
take our research problems from the real
world
Carnegie Mellon is very good at that and
we will move the results back out into
the real world in addition we will
educate a large number of students who
can go out into the world and and have
big impact on the way in which we
develop and use energy resources we'll
do a variety of things in outreach that
is both for expert decision-makers and
also for the general public with the
objective of working to better inform
public discourse on energy related
issues Carnegie Mellon is really unique
among major research universities we
work on the technical we work on the
policy we work on the behavioral and
social dimensions
but we are unique in the world to be
able to take a systems approach and
integrate all these different approaches
in one piece of seamless research
you